it's that time in the show where we give  struggling artists their shot at stardom  in a segment i like to call dionco's big  break  [Applause]  [Music]  so many songs have been written about  young romance but tyler winters really  captured the essence of burning love  girl you're my std you become a part of  me  [Music]  my sexy team dream  [Applause]  that song is contagious  [Applause]  but just when you think the song can't  get any better  rapper storm cloud makes a guest  appearance the storm cloud  check check check them out check them  out check the mic one two cuz anywhere  we wanna go you're that where we gonna  go you and me baby ain't nothing but me  i got my air hockey baby  [Music]  you've become a part of me  that girl in the video must be psyched